thank you
well hey everybody what's going on how's
your weekend going it's Sunday we're
very tired yeah
but you know what I mean
but we wanted to come on and talk about
this movie like I said we had seen some
movie like a bunch of movies so I wasn't
sure which one we were going to talk
about but we decided we were going to
talk about Dreamscape yeah because this
was a movie that
I saw several times like back in the 80s
because I feel like it was on cable I
don't think I saw it in the theater I
might have but um
I saw it like a bunch of times on cable
or I rented it or something like that
and I remembered like really liking it
but I hadn't seen it since then so I was
like really when I saw that it was
available what did we watch it on 2B or
I don't even remember what we watched it
on but I remembered uh liking it and I
was just like well I kind of want to
revisit it and see if it was just as
good as I remembered and honestly I
think it holds up it's still kind of you
know the special effects are not like
super great and everything like because
it was the 80s and it was kind of a low
budget I think it only cost six million
dollars to make it
um so you know so some of the special
effects work is kind of you know you can
tell it wasn't the most expensive but
not even back then yeah but people
weren't picky about that kind of [__]
back then yeah that's true I mean I
remember seeing I remember seeing this
movie and liking it at the time as a kid
and we were just like oh wow look at the
snake monster and oh yeah look at this
yeah look at the look at the uh the
burned out [__] uh Washington DC and
it was all little Miniatures and stuff
but uh I enjoyed it back at the time I
think I saw this in the theater when it
came out and then they played it on HBO
played it a lot yeah it seemed like it
was on all the time it was
kind of like a big deal when the movie
came out it was kind of like Altered
States or some kind of Michael Crichton
flick you know Westworld type of [__]
you know uh it reminded me a lot of a
Michael Crichton flick with it you know
kind of centering on
mind powers and technology and the
government involved with [__] like
dream Invasion abilities and
um
but at the time I don't know which came
first if if Altered States came first or
this one came first yeah I think Altered
States came out in 1981.
wasn't it and when did this come out 84.
okay so I'm pretty sure Altered States
was before this it also kind of reminded
me of like uh Stephen the Stephen King
movies involving mind Powers you know
like fire starter Fire Starter yeah it's
very much like that like that I had
forgotten how much of this I mean I
remembered like the dream sequences and
I remembered kind of like the the
overall premise of like people going
into people's dreams but I didn't really
remember like the the conspiratorial
like political thriller angle that this
is because this has like a very much 70s
political thriller kind of thing but and
a lot of people it's because I was
reading like other reviews of this a lot
of people have pointed out that much
later movies that came out like the cell
which is the one with uh Jennifer Lopez
and um Inception kind of I'm not gonna
say ripped off the plot of this but
they're exploring very similar themes
you know what I mean I haven't seen the
cell in a long time I liked it at the
time but that kind of has a very similar
plot to this I feel like doesn't it at
least what I remember I haven't seen the
cell in a long time yeah I'd like to see
it sell again 1980 Altered States came
out thank you I said 81 I was close all
right
so uh so this is might have been heavily
influenced by Altered States it does
remind me of Altered States a little bit
a little bit but you mentioned in the
cell man I want to see that one again I
remember really liking that it had a
bunch of it's a cool imagery where she
goes into that serial killers
mind yeah and sees all the weird [__]
and everything and JLo looked [__]
great man [__] I don't think we were
freed that movie did we maybe we should
get around to doing that I think that's
really the only from my memory that was
the only interesting movie She Made
I feel like she was mainly in well she I
think she was in some other good [__]
too but I think she mainly was in kind
of like romantic comedy type things at
least for my perception I don't know I
remember that she was pretty good in it
yeah yeah I remember her I remember
liking her in it yeah I remember and
that booty man God that's what everybody
talks about yeah that was the big her
booty is famous yeah that was the
beginning of [__] white dudes [__]
uh getting into the thick look Halo yeah
yeah she's badass
but yeah so that's another movie we
should do but yeah I was reminded of it
because somebody pointed out they're
like you know the cell has like
essentially the same plot as Dreamscape
like pretty much which it kind of does
the think about it so this movie was
actually directed by a guy named Joseph
Rubin and he lit and that name kind of
sounded familiar to me and that is
because later on he actually directed
The Stepfather which was a great [__]
horror movie that came out 87 I think
and he also did Sleeping with the Enemy
the Julia Roberts film which was also
awesome and he did the good Sun from
1990 with Macaulay Culkin as like the
evil kid
um which was also great so he did a lot
of really good movies and the thing
about this one the movie made money like
I said it was kind of it was pretty
cheap to make it was only six million
dollars and it made like double its
budget back so that was like a moderate
financial success or whatever what our
regulars are demanding that we review
the sale yeah the cell by C by Stephen
King no no
um that one yeah Stephen King wrote one
called cell which was just like about
itself like an infection virus type of
thing
um which I think they made a movie out
of that but I didn't see it because it
didn't look that great and I didn't like
the book actually but um no the cell is
about
uh Jennifer Lopez going into she's like
an investigator of some kind right or
yeah she goes into the mind of a serial
killer into like the mind of a serial
killer to figure out like figure out the
location of like one of the last victims
being held in some secret cell somewhere
that's going to get flooded with water
if they don't figure out where she is
and they can save her in time yeah it's
a good flick yeah because there's all
kinds of weird imagery when she gets
into a serial killer yeah it's cool mind
in his mind he's a god-like being and
everything and there's victims in there
and like in animals horses being sliced
apart by [__] yeah that was that's a
that was a very indelible image I
remember spread the horse that was
[__] weird he he had it and uh and
then it it's just a good movie yeah it
was good and JLo looks really got good
in it and when she enters into his mind
he sees her the way he wants to see her
and she looks like some kind of Gothic
Japanese goddess when she's in there
[__] it's a good flick a real good
yeah am I crazy or was that movie The
Cell directed by the same guy that
directed that um REM video Losing My
Religion I don't know maybe I mean in a
long time I don't remember I didn't
remember anything I don't know why I
don't know why I associate those two
things so it might be the same guy I
think I only saw that movie twice and I
just saw it on VHS yeah or dvd probably
I saw it a couple years ago and I
remember like I was like oh this really
holds up yeah but um I can't remember
what year it came out though yeah it was
90s right wasn't it 90s or was it early
2000s early 2000s I think I think
because I think I saw it on DVD yeah
yeah slasher Fred points out yeah this
is another thing that I wanted to get
into it's ironic that this movie uh
Dreamscape came out the same year the
original Nightmare on Elm Street which
also has a character in the form of
Freddy Krueger who has the talent to
enter Dreams yeah and the crazy thing I
think they only came out like three
months apart so it wasn't like one was
ripping off the other one it was just
kind of like that was in sort of in the
Zeitgeist the thing about it though I
feel like
and something that they said about this
on the Wikipedia page
but Dreamscape was evidently based on a
novel sort of like Loosely and the novel
I think came out in the 60s you know I
think it was called the dream master and
it was kind of it was a lot different
but it was basically about people that
could go inside other people's dreams
and like you know and shape their
whatever and so
um the guy that wrote the novel who's I
can't remember what his name was of
zavatanis about something like that but
um I can't remember what his name was
but he wrote an outline for this movie
and I guess the production company the
movie production company bought the
outline but then they changed it so much
that they didn't even put his name on
the [__] yeah you know what I mean
because it wasn't really which like I
said I kind of read a synopsis of the
novel and it's
sort of similar but not really like they
went like a totally different Direction
with it all the only thing that's
similar is because his was like set way
in the future because it was more sci-fi
this has a Sci-Fi element but I don't
know what cut what genre would you call
this it's kind of like sci-fi Adventure
paranormal paranormal like it's got some
horror imagery in it for sure to me it
was like a conspiracy Thriller too it
was in the same
genre as the Michael Crichton flicks
like
um uh uh oh Andromeda Strain yeah and uh
this isn't quite as dry as that yeah a
lot of his movies are kind of dry a lot
of them are kind of dry but and then the
one where uh you know they were using AI
to find the perfect model for physical
whatever those one where they shot
liquor yeah so we were made that a while
back some about this movie reminds me
it's kind of like an improved version of
those movies yeah or some where it
almost feels almost like a documentary
in a certain way but not it's like
they're trying to there's a feeling of
that they're trying to convince you that
these Technologies are real and the
government knows about them yeah and it
the way it's portrayed is it is kind of
credible like yeah they probably are
doing that
yeah it's totally grounded yeah it's
grounded maximum side I was in it he
knocks it out of the park that
motherfucker's awesome and everything I
love maximum all-star cast president's
played by the dude who plays [__]
from Green Acres yeah uh Eddie Albert
yeah yeah he's the president the main
bad guys that little [__] with
the big head from [__] Commando Sully
and he goes I lied and [__] and yeah
that guy that dude drops him he's good
in this one that dude was in the
Warriors too he was the guy that goes
Warriors
he is a creepy little [__] um
but uh he does he he does a real good
job with this movie yeah he's like well
one of the villains he's a little skinny
weedy little [__] in this world
but in the dream world he's basically
Freddy Krueger and a lot of the [__]
Freddy Krueger does they rip off from
this movie but like I said the blades
the weird thing yeah but the weird thing
is they were working on this movie I
think at the same time so I don't know
yeah they must have been trading crew
because there is a scene toward the end
of this movie where
um the bad guy whose name is Tommy Ray
yeah he's in the dream they're all in
the dream and it's like Dennis Quaid is
in there and the president is in there
and it's the president's dream and
they're all inside they're like having a
battle royale and um so Tommy Ray oh
yeah like his fingers grow not like you
know Freddy Krueger blades or nothing
like that but that's two inches long
yeah like he has little blades and he
like sticks and pulls somebody's heart
out yeah he tries to pull the present's
heart out no it's the train it was the
train conductor no it was the cop the
extra cop on the train yeah that's what
it was that was trying to like yeah
because the whole thing about because
okay so if you don't know and I was so
like I was saying before like a long
time ago I think the reason that this
movie didn't make a [__] ton of money in
the theaters like it just did sort of
like if so so is because I'm not sure
they marketed it correctly because this
came out I mean it had cake Capshaw in
it and so they were trying to capitalize
on her recent appearance in Indiana
Jones and the Temple of Doom so if you
see the original theatrical poster for
this which is actually really nice I
like the poster of this but it looks
like an Indiana Jones poster and indeed
it was done by the same artist that did
the Indiana Jones poster so you could
tell that they were trying to make it
look like an adventure movie you know
Dennis Quaid's there was like a torch
like that [__] doesn't happen in a movie
no so it's a cool poster yeah it's cool
but it's it's not really like what the
movie is it was a cool movie it is yeah
somebody mentioned coma that was another
movie the [__] yeah yeah we reviewed
that last year yeah a couple years ago
it's along those lines yeah but um
more juicy like I said like Jenny said
what's his name uh crichton's flicks are
kind of dry they are yeah uh this one's
a little more for the average person a
little more crowd pleaser proud pleasing
not so fan service and [__] not so high
falutin right
um but there's still something about it
that's kind of clinical and I think that
might be I think that might be that had
good sets that were believable like in
the secret base where they're trying to
figure out how to enter into people's
dreams all the technology and [__] and
maximize side out makes the movie real
serious because if he shows up you're
gonna believe this [__] yeah he
he just has that credibility yeah you're
gonna believe this is some real [__]
you're getting ready to see yeah and uh
so he does a real good job at it and I
must say on the side Capshaw is much
better in this movie than she is
this one she kind of plays a a better
character it's the writing and she does
a real serious role and she's hot man
she's hotter than this than she is in
Temple of Doom and I think they tried to
make her look hotter in Temple of Doom
it was kind of a sexy roll but there's
just something about her in this one
because she appears in certain dream
sequences
and she's kind of hot in it there's just
something about her I was watching this
other I can't remember what channel it
was but I was watching this other guy's
review of this movie and he called her
mom hot yeah no he said 100 mom hot yeah
you'd call her mom now but back in those
days she was more like the chick next
door that's what chick you worked with
at the office yeah and he he's probably
my age which meant that in this era that
would have been his mom right because he
was like 12 when this [__]
and the way they dress you know [__]
sweater over the [__] shoulder with
the doctor you know just all that
[__]
these lame-ass Yuppie preppy [__] I mean
yeah there's like some terrible clothing
terrible [__] 80s clothes and her
hair I don't love her hair in this one
either it's that mainstream but that was
yeah that was how people wore their hair
back then yeah I don't know Farrah
Fawcett it was the next evolution of
Farrah Fawcett everybody's hair looked
like totally fried fried out [__]
like a poodle
[__] weird
that's right you probably had to like
shave it off like if I could to [__]
recover but yeah so the premise of this
movie if you haven't seen it Dennis
Quaid
plays this dude who is a psychic and
they kind of are like um when he was
younger like when he was 19 because they
show like all this like old footage of
him that they had like he was
um in this you know psychic
parapsychological study or whatever and
he could do like all this amazing [__]
but it's like after that he decided he
didn't really want to do it anymore so
he just kind of like absconded and then
he started using his psychic powers just
to like win a bunch of money at the
track and seduce the ladies and that
kind of [__] but it turns out that
because of all this money he's winning
at the track like he gets in trouble
with some gangsters or some [__] like
that so it ends up
that uh Max von sato's character who I
guess was like his mentor or whatever
like years back at the college
parapsychology lab
he actually tracks the Dude down and
he's like well we're gonna bring him in
because we're doing this new big project
that has to like we figured out a way
for people with these kind of talents to
like go into other people's dreams so
they're kind of like farting around with
and I think Max monsaido is actually
like a good guy in this yeah so the um
the research didn't they say they wanted
it to um kind of get to help people that
had like PTSD and [__] like that kind of
the cover story well that was that I
think that's what Max von Seidel wanted
to do like with it but of course CIA had
ulterior moves right yeah involved in
there thank you Jeffy all right they
found out that if you killed somebody in
a dream they died in real life so you
could assassinate somebody but you
needed the right kind of psychic enter
the little [__] come out and play
dude yeah Tommy Ray that's not the
actor's name what's that actor's name um
it is uh David Patrick Kelly David
Patrick Kelly okay he doesn't get much
more Irish than that does it even name
it all he needs is a mick a mick in
there
yeah
okay but uh in a Sheamus yeah he also
needs a shame and I thought he I thought
he did a great job in this movie and
that's a very interesting character he's
he's unlikable you just like him
and uh but then when he's in the dream
world he's just a Weasley little [__]
nobody you know what I mean like you
just want to crush him you know yeah for
being a dick but in the dream world he's
a [__] Juggernaut okay he's a [__]
martial arts fan he saw a [__] he
says this in the movies he's got [__]
Kung Fu posters all around his [__]
the room that they keep him in he's seen
[__] Enter the Dragon nine times or
whatever and I think he said six times
six times
and he acted like that all the time
which I'm sure made him like really
endeared him to the rest of the game yes
I'm sure and that was he acted like a
dick and then
and thought he was a ninja and I can go
into your dreams and yeah and then he'd
turn into something like Freddy with
[__] blades coming out of his figures
and then he turned into a damn snake man
because he saw it a little boy's dream
which is part of the story and it's and
he realized that that with that
alternate image you could terrorize
people so he turned into a snake man
vaguely had his face and it's claymation
old school Practical effects yeah it's
like stop motion yeah stop motion
claymation you know it looks like
something might have Clash of the Titans
or something I think initially they had
a dude in a costume because I saw some
of the like behind the scenes photos but
then they did it and they did thought it
didn't look good enough yeah so they did
good stop motion instead yeah which that
didn't look good either but it was it
was it was probably better than it did I
imagine like I said this was a quite a
low budget yeah film and the audiences
at the time were used to Ray harryhausen
stuff that was just the accepted Norm
okay you know the stop motion Ray Harry
housing style monster you could get away
with it that's what they used and uh I
remember seeing it as a kid and liking
it like oh yeah yeah like you know kind
of like a Godzilla movie you're kind of
like a [__] Sinbad you know but
only in retrospect looking at it as an
adult you see how how much that visual
effect has aged yeah yeah I mean but it
was all practical effects though so you
got to give them the movie credit you
know it was they didn't do a real good
job with the limited budget a lot of
imagination a lot of good writing the
writing in the in the story is good all
the dialogue's pretty good yeah nobody
says anything [__] stupid no
everything makes sense too nothing is
like illogical it all makes sense in
them in the movie it holds up the only
thing that I wish that they had done was
more nightmare sequences yeah because I
think those are really because the thing
about it is that I mean the main plot
really is well you know that you don't
actually find out until later on is this
the whole like assassination of the
president because you have Christopher
Plummer who's [__] great
and he always plays like these kind of
yeah sleazy ass roles like like sleazy
corporate kind of role and he's like the
the Shady like CIA spook dude that's
like yeah this is this is why we're
developing this technology or this is
why we're funding this technology
um we're telling you guys that it's all
for the good of mankind and stuff but
really we're gonna go in people's dreams
because if you have somebody that can go
in anyone's dream and kill them in their
dream and then they die in real life
then you have plausible deniability
right so they can just like kill anybody
so he's kind of like and we're just
gonna kill the president because he's
been having nightmares about a nuclear
Holocaust and he's gonna go and like
make peace with the Russians and we
can't have that so you know what I mean
so there's that whole like like I said
so that has like a political thriller
thing but going up to that there's kind
of like episodes where Dennis Quaid goes
into a couple people's dreams so he goes
in and there's actually like a funny
like comic relief kind of thing which
actually doesn't even play into the
larger plot at all I remembered it as a
kid though but I saw it again I was like
oh this is what I remembered yeah
he thought his wife was cheating on him
yeah he like comes in yeah and he's been
having all these nightmares that his
wife is cheating on him so Dennis Quaid
like goes into this dude's dream and
he's just like this kind of schlubby
well it's a little more to it than that
okay he was he was he was having bad
dreams
about her cheating on him and he was
having [__] erectile dysfunction yeah
couldn't get it up
the dude was okay you you couldn't do
this today okay there was kind of an
ethnic [__] Dynamic to the to the
relationship you know you got a Jewish
director here this guy was a little
Jewish guy and by his accent somewhere
[__] from New York okay he's married
this [__] hot blonde shiksa you know
okay
Gentile chick and she he thinks that
he's like on a physical scale one to ten
is dudes like a three
little short Duppy dude you know what I
mean in these middle aged 50s okay this
uh this [__] says [__] badass
probably makes maybe 30 at like eight
you know so he thinks that she just
married him for his money and he's got
all his mental problems about it he
can't get it up so they're going
undergoing therapy part of the
experiment was to go in there and help
this guy [__] get his mojo back
so Dennis Quaid this is one of his first
missions is to go into this guy's dreams
and the dream is [__] hilarious and I
remembered the [__] it was so [__]
hilarious I remembered it it's a
masterpiece [__] seed I'll let Jenny
tell the [__] story about what he did
he he wakes up Dennis quaints in this
other dude's dream and he's driving the
car and he goes you gotta watch him
every second are you scared you're not
scared yeah yeah
I'm gonna go in the front door I'm gonna
go in the back door we're going to catch
her like it like it's gonna be like this
big [__] yeah
we're gonna catch her and they're
running up the stairs together and you
can hear her up there just getting
knocked the [__] down what the [__] are
they filming porn up there and
everything and it's all red like the
house is awesome watch we got her we got
her you know he [__] runs into the
door like that and she she's just
getting Slammy and he goes my own
brother and he goes sorry man and in
front of the children and the children
next to the bed going high they were
watching and then and then three or four
more dudes come out underneath the
[__] bed and then his [__]
Japanese client that he worked with is
by the you two you know isn't Itachi you
too and he's like yeah well yeah
you know it was just [__] hilarious
and in front of the children you know
and they were sitting here in the chair
I busted up laughing at that part I had
a nightmare I had totally forgotten that
it and in front of the children and I
was like yeah that was awesome it was
great and the two kids are just sitting
there in the chair like watching their
mom getting like railed by all these
yeah yeah there's dudes underneath the
bed hiding and chilling that's so funny
that was his nightmare man but it's just
well so that I love that scene but it's
just I'm just saying that it doesn't
really have anything to do with like it
was just like a comic relief kind of
scene just showing you hey Dennis Quaid
can go into other people's dreams
because the main part like so it's kind
of like episodic at the beginning I feel
like where he's just going into the
dream because he goes into the dreams of
this one kid whose name is Buddy and
Buddy is like can't even sleep anymore
because he's just having these [__]
horrible nightmares like every and the
first psychic that goes into Buddy's
dream loses his mind like they have to
take him away like he's just like and
they have to like take him away like in
a butterfly net or whatever and um so
Dennis went is like I really want to
help this kid because I used to have
nightmares too and I know and he like
the kid looks like [__] like he's got
like these big [__] black you know uh
bags under his eyes and [__] like that
so he goes in there and then he finds
out that that I love that dream sequence
actually like where he first meets The
Snake Man like he goes in a buddy's
dream it's not just the snake man
because I really do like the snake man
too but I really like the house is all
like weird like surreal looking like
it's got like weird shaped doors like in
Nosferatu and [__] like you know it's
like German Expressions I have too and
it's like so I thought that was really
cool and I also really liked the scene
where uh you know Dennis Quaid and Buddy
and they go and then and then the kid's
dad is like sitting at the end of this
long dining table and but he's like oh
well don't even talk to him because he
doesn't he won't he won't help us yeah
and it's just like I like that I thought
that was like really creepy like that
was really good the way they did that
yeah and they had to fight that damn
monster and it turns out the little kid
vanquishes the monster yeah it was just
so they did
but the Snake Man does make an
appearance later because after Dennis
Quaid like because he's like holy [__]
this is like this world scary stream or
whatever and then he draws the snake
monster and then like the evil psychic
like finds it and he's like oh I'm gonna
use this [__] for like future purpose I
don't remember if they ever helped the
dude with the erectile dysfunction did
they
I guess not yeah did they resolve that I
don't think it was I think his dream was
so bizarre they just kind of went
what are we gonna do with this guy
they're like well
and they never really and they never
specified if she actually was like
cheating on him or not I imagine not but
um in his mind she was in his mind she
was just like banging everybody yeah
like dudes are climbing out from under
the bed the bed's like a [__] clown
cars characters guys are coming up
but holy [__] there's like an anxiety
dream you'd have dreams like that where
you're talking you're pissed off your
teeth start falling out and hitting the
ground oh my God I have something I have
so many dreams it was like that yeah and
well the weird thing about it is that
and I think that's a pretty common uh
dream for people to have like teeth
falling out
um and it's always like it'll be in a
dream that's like about something else
like it'll just be this random dream and
then all of a sudden random feeling of
powerlessness because I think one time
like I was dreaming like something
really mundane like oh I was in the
McDonald's drive-through or something
like that and then like all my teeth
started falling out I've had dreams
where I was in firefight [__] fired
off [__] powerful rounds and slowly
with each shot the [__] bullets get
weaker and weaker until the rounds just
fall out of the barrel I'm shaking it
like that and rounds are falling out I
can't shoot anybody bullets
zigging past me [__] just I think I
think it's the same dream as having your
teeth fall out yeah it's like a
helplessness yeah of helplessness
powerlessness I'm pretty sure that makes
sense thank you murder Hornet for
returning to flash bulbs yes he said he
let it lapse again okay don't let that
happen no I'm just
but um but yeah so so after that like
after they uncover you know the plot to
and I forgot to mention like [__]
George Wendt is in this too and like as
soon as he turned and I laughed because
the first scene where they introduce him
he's in a bar so of course everyone had
to go Norm you know what I mean because
that's just what you do when you see
George went he probably is so [__]
sick of that but um but yeah so he plays
like this author that is researching
this you know dream research that
they're doing and he's like yeah I know
that like it's super shady and they're
gonna use it to assassinate people and
[__] like that and then he gets his ass
killed but um but yeah so so that kind
of whole thing uh is how that turns up
now let's talk about the one scene that
um
that I was kind of like oh that's kind
of [__] up that it's the scene where
because Dennis Quaid is um you know he
was quite young in this I think he had
been in Jaws 3D prior to this
um that was hard to believe yeah yeah
like just a year or two prior yeah so
that was like his first big main role I
think because he's still really young in
this and um so he's just kind of like
this sort of charming Devil May care
kind of character
and he um immediately like has the hots
for Kate Capshaw as character who's one
of the doctors who's working on the [__]
and he's just like trying to [__]
smarm you know and she's just like nah
you know we're working together I don't
think of professional blah blah but then
she happens to be like sleeping
conveniently in her office one day and
he just goes in there and is like huh I
think that I'm just gonna fall asleep
too and just like sneak right into her
dream and I'm just like dude that's not
right but um I mean the reason that that
plot point was in there because you know
it showed that oh now he can do it
without the machine because prior to
that he had to have the machine with all
the electrodes and [__] like that like
to get from one dream in another dream
but he's just but he's just like um I
think because I think Max von Seidel
says at one point oh would you get good
enough at it like you won't need the
machine anymore so this is like the
first time where Dennis Quaid like does
it where he doesn't need the machine so
he goes into Kate capshaw's dream and it
so happens that she's like dreaming
she's on a train and then he's in there
going like hey what's up and then they
just start [__] yeah and so anyways I
think they full-on [__] I think they
cut some of that out actually like
before they theatrically release it
because I thought it was to but it is a
little bit steamy but you know what I
mean so then I mean so she wakes up and
she's like you [__] like what
because like I said if you because she
was wearing a dream I know but it's like
that's still not I mean that's still not
cool because I've had dreams that you
know that um I don't know if I
necessarily had dreams where I had sex
with somebody and I woke up and I was
like what the [__] gross but you know
what I mean so just because you dream
something that doesn't mean that you
actually want that to happen well it
also doesn't mean that that happened
right it's a dream I know but still if
but I I'm just saying hypothetically so
funny hypothetically if you had the
ability to go into somebody's dream yeah
that's kind of I kind of feel like
that's not a cool thing to do like
without them knowing about it no I went
in there and met her and she wanted to
have sex with him they would they wanted
to have sex they would they had the hots
for each other I know that but I'm just
saying that he didn't know that because
she had turned him down already because
he asked her out I still think it's like
not cool to like go in somebody's dream
without without them knowing about it
that's pushing boundaries that's like
saying you can't go to that club because
that girl that you know is at that club
and you might have sex with no that's
not the same thing he just went into her
dream it's not the same but when she
went into the dream she was in the train
so he goes to the train because I feel
well the thing about it is it wasn't
real like I said I feel like one just
because you dream something that doesn't
mean you want it to happen so it's like
and dreams that's that's like reading
people's thoughts like without their
consent that's kind of creepy
the psychic abilities man it's kind of
creepy you can't prove it I know but I'm
just saying that it's still kind of
creepy like doing that without because
she was mad and it's like yeah I'd be
mad too like don't be doing that yeah
they ended up dating at the end though I
know they did but I'm just yeah but I'm
just saying that I still think that was
kind of a [__] up thing for him to do
yeah
Jeffrey Hart said some scenes just won't
uh it just won't always age well yeah
and like I said they did show that she
was mad about it but um you know and he
did Apologize he's like yeah that was
[__] up like I shouldn't have done
that and I was like yeah you shouldn't
have done that but then like in the end
she's like man I wanted to hump anyway
so it's fine but you know what I mean
I'm just saying that she didn't fight
him off I don't yeah I just don't think
because well he was like a boundary
pushing [__] too because there
was a scene prior to that where he kind
of asked her out and she was like nah I
don't think we should do that because
like we're working together and it's not
professional or whatever and then he
kind of came in and just like kind of
kissed her even after she said no and I
was like it was just a thing of the time
I know well that's what I'm saying I
don't I don't know if he did with that
nowadays
religion was still a factor yeah you
know it's like that in in Latin culture
today
because they're Catholic the girl has to
say no all right and then the next then
she's gonna be making out with you if I
can
20 minutes later anyway because she she
wanted it
she was into you but they have to say
though you have to get past the no
though it's not a real no it's a not all
the time you know what I mean
because
South America will [__] slap you if
that's what no is you know but no they
they like to be pursued it's part of
Latin culture
you have to overcome objections because
she's doing this because she has to over
she should protect her honor and do all
her religious duties to be see I wasn't
I'm not a [__] you know I mean you're
gonna have to ask me a couple times but
that's usually how it is well like I
said and I kind of feel that that was
kind of well yeah and I feel like that
turned up a lot like an 80s movies yeah
well and one example I bring up a lot
too is like Revenge of the Nerds where
there's a scene where the girl she's not
drunk or anything like that but the dude
one of the Nerds like dresses up in her
boyfriend's costume and has sex with her
and I'm like
not that's rape yeah yeah
is what that is yeah but I'm J you know
because you're you're misrepresenting
yourself you're pretending that you're
your boyfriend who she would have sex
with willingly and you're some other
[__] random [__] wouldn't
have had sex with him back then a
Hollywood executive would have thought
that was a Hollywood director would have
thought that was just like racy comedy
yeah that's what I mean yeah and it's
like and it's not I'm just like yeah I
don't remember dudes doing that
that was just something you saw in a
movie well yeah but I'm just saying that
it's back in the 80s like people didn't
have a problem with it and I was just
kind of all kinds of watching it now is
just like [__] horrifying there's all
kinds of weird shits like Animal House
and porkies and [__] stupid movies
like that had all kinds of ridiculous
American Virgin they're [__] all
kinds of ridiculous [__] in there that
you'd go to prison for if you did yeah
big time even back then you'd go to
prison for it yeah uh but but there's
just like I know it's fine yeah it's
fine it's just a movie it's always funny
it's all a good song
yeah Tammy said so if a drunk woman
passes out and doesn't fight the guy off
yeah yeah yeah yeah well I mean that was
kind of that would actually appear in
movies sometimes yeah that's and I was
gonna say that was in movies too and
that is absolutely not okay it was okay
back then yeah even back then although I
think that back then I don't know I kind
of feel like people wouldn't have
thought it was as bad
as you know as they would nowadays but I
don't know it was still seen as [__]
up back then yeah but the thing about it
is I think that even back in the 80s the
scene in Dreamscape where he goes into
her dream like without her knowing about
it or saying it was okay
um you know they seem to realize that it
was bad because like she was mad and he
did Apologize he's like yeah I shouldn't
have done that that was [__] up so
they did seem to realize that it was
like not a cool thing to do they didn't
really play it for well they did play it
for laughs at the beginning because
they're like oh look it's funny that
she's into him but they hump in the
dream and but it didn't happen like that
that's right no I know that was that was
the that was the disclaimer it didn't
happen yeah it's like it's not real it's
not real yeah but still it's not cool to
go in somebody else's dream unless they
know about it if you want to do like
Mutual dream that'd be cool Spirit
[__]
your spirit their Spirit you're the
spirit that's what I mean but it's like
everybody has to know what's going on
you can't just like go and find some
napping assets I'm gonna go in that
bitch's dream and see what's going on in
there that's not going into her dream
and she [__] him I was like you know
don't do that but uh but yeah so that's
yeah so what I wanted to talk about that
but I also liked
because like I said I think it needed
more horror I think it needed more
nightmare sequences in it although I did
like the the president's dreams that he
showed like with the it was all like a
post-apocalyptic landscape with all the
like Washington DC and everything was
all red yeah one of the main subplots of
the movie is that
the president of the United States is
having these reoccurring nightmares of
nuclear Armageddon like he's the one
responsible
that he started nuclear war and then and
destroyed the world in America so he's
getting ready to go to this big Summit
and the CIA knows about these dreams
that he's having and they're afraid that
he's going to sign this like
non-proliferation treaty and
um hamper their ability to like have a
nuclear response and that the Russians
would take advantage of this and [__]
annihilate this type of deal
so they're gonna
I think then they first try to get him
to change his dream I don't remember
they ended up they were going to use
their assassin little little ninja boy
to give to kill the president in his
dream yeah because just like in
Nightmare on Elm Street if you die in
your dream you die in real life that way
they could get another president one
that wouldn't sign that non-learn for
proliferation
he's not even drinking not even drinking
seriously just sleep
we're gonna put another president in
there to see how he could control better
yeah so they're like ooh now we have
this guy because what they did with
Tommy Ray yeah the bad psychic
um they had him like hook up to this
just like random old woman who would
come in for you know for therapy or
whatever and unbeknownst to everybody
else that was working at the facility uh
Christopher Plummer's character the bad
CIA spook guy he told us like hey I want
you to kill that [__] like in the dream
and we'll see what happens like we'll
see if this works so he just and it just
looked like the old lady had a heart
attack and they were like oh too bad so
sad you know what I mean [__] happens
but they didn't realize that he had done
it on purpose yeah so they're gonna
kill the president
uh using ninja dream boy
what's his name Tommy Ray yeah Tommy Ray
and the Dennis Quaid character he's he
has to Buck up and be the hero and save
the president inside the president's
Dreams yeah they all got to go into
drinking so it's almost kind of like a
dream fisticuffs yeah like a spiritual
Escape From New York where snake
plisskin
save the president in the [__] Dream
from the from the thing but he's saving
him from snake twist and a big snake
oh I like how you I like how you like
Jessica right into that that was really
good yeah because it was a Cobra too
except snake Pleasant's Cobra came up
out of his pants there's that tattoo on
his side he knows that which uh yeah
they were trying to say his dick was
just a [__] Cobra Spitz
[Laughter]
yeah Jeffrey art is saying he should
have at least wooed her with a romantic
dream picnic first right that's what I
mean you should have at least bought her
dinner in the dream before you just got
on the train and he got on a train your
eyes locked and the next thing you know
it was getting busy
she was sucking through her she just
threw herself on his [__] spiritual
[__]
like climbing up on stings lingam
never gonna let that go never yeah
cheerleading you absolating uh
her yanny
or what is it Steven Seagal calls it uh
poonanny yeah
yeah Steven Seagal would use a word like
that he would yeah because he's just
grossed and oily that's a gross oily
Asian experience yeah in this in the
pool oh my God so nasty but um but yeah
well and uh wait I was gonna say I was
gonna say something else [__] I just
totally forgot what it was you just used
distracted you distracted me with all
with all the lingam and the poonanny
yeah it's like 70. oh what I was gonna
say was that at the very end of this
movie when you know the bad guys are
vanquished I have to say too I mean
spoiler alert this movie came out like
[__] a long time ago
um in 1984 but at the end they're like
well the CIA spook guy Christopher
Plummer it's like well we can't have
that dude just like run around loose so
Dennis Quaid is like hey I'm gonna like
um you know use some of his own medicine
against him I'm gonna go in his dream
and [__] kill his stupid ass so he
like assassinated he did like what he
was horrified at he said he's like oh
like we shouldn't be doing that that's
wrong and he's like but I'm just gonna
do it at the end just as one time just
to kill that guy because he's super
dangerous but so like after that like
after everybody gets defeated and it's
all like a happy ending and stuff so
then
so then Dennis Quaid and Kate Kate
Capshaw get on the train at the eggs
they're like we're gonna do this [__] in
real life and then the guy that was like
the um the ticket collector dude that
was in her dream is in there in real
life and I'm like what are they implying
there are they like that's what I'm
saying so was it like she saw that guy
in real life because they showed him
like close up in the dream but they were
trying to imply is that the sexual
encounter they had in the dream was
actually a prediction of the future of
what was gonna happen
yeah because I mean he was psychic right
yeah that it was well and then didn't
she say at the end oh maybe she was a
little psychic too because it was her
dream yeah so they had predicted what
was gonna happen yeah
in that dream but then it was also kind
of like a self-fulfilling prophecy
because well the conductor was the proof
yeah because they saw that conductor in
the dream yeah so they were seeing the
future and lived they were living they
lived out the future
that's kind of that's kind of a lame
thing to see in the future though it's
like you know if you could see the
future it's like I want to see the
lottery numbers or if the if this
plane's gonna crash or something like
that it's like well I I all we saw was
like we [__] on a train it was a love
story
goes into a dream and they see what
they're gonna do they're gonna get busy
on the train and the conductor is going
to be there and everything the Kentucky
is going to be there watching when you
see that he goes yeah okay we dream true
yeah I've had all that [__] happen to me
dreaming true
uh seeing other people's dreams I've had
out of body experiences did you ever did
you ever have a dream that you had sex
with Kate capture on a train no I wish
that I wish I did though
yeah no protection or anything
because it's a dream nothing bad's gonna
happen [__] get her ass pregnant
[__] years later I'm looking at her
[__] children I go man that dude
looks just like me
I dreamed true
I dream and then there's like all these
little Toms yeah like that one kid looks
just like me
she married Steven Spielberg didn't she
yeah that's right yeah I know were they
married how I placed my cuckoo bird
just like him for Fairy like the berry
I'm in the Spielberg family
right
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're smoking abandoned that's right
I know
[Music]
my loins
yeah we did we were bead Smokey and the
Bandit didn't we I don't know I think we
did because we just we got remember we
got we went off on like another southern
original yeah we went off on like a
whole Burt Reynolds too you remember
because I'm pretty sure we did Smokey in
the Bandit and we did Gator yeah and we
did like a bunch of other ones that he
that he was in White Lightning White
Lightning yeah that's right because yeah
for some reason I think we did Malone
too yeah yeah like is it well because
once you watch one movie then all the
other ones get suggested I'm like oh I
remember that would be a good team for
rentals I think as far as I know that's
like the only Southern Action Hero yeah
he was actually hero
yeah Tammy is saying uh yeah I was just
thinking I want to see the winning
lottery numbers yeah it's just well and
the thing about it is that I did kind of
like that in the very beginning of the
movie Dennis Quaid he's like yeah I'm
just gonna use my psychic abilities to
like win all this money at like the
horse racing track because that's I mean
that's what I would do why wouldn't you
if you could actually psychically see
like which horses were gonna win or what
the lottery numbers where lunches do
that and like not [__] around anymore
you know that's what I would do
well
you read a uh you read that book dream I
think it's called dream Warrior no
psychic Warrior so it's called there was
that uh guy that uh was in the [__]
what was that project Stargate us Army's
version of remote viewers
and they tried all that they tried to do
things like see combinations and see
words and letters they evidently
couldn't
couldn't get it real exact
data you know I mean like trying to look
at [__] secret documents and some
kind of Vault over in the Soviet Union
they could see the Vault they could see
paper but they couldn't they could see
words or letters but they couldn't make
them out
well like I said I was just talking like
hypothetically hypothetically if you
could if your psychic abilities were
that honed that you could actually
the way the fabric of the universe works
uh you're not allowed to cheat
that way for some reason I guess
although maybe some people that did
actually win the lottery maybe they are
psychic but they don't want to tell
anybody they would have won more than
once and the only person that did that
was my uh uncle Ronnie my granddad some
people have he run yeah but it was
corruption well yeah I had friends in
the gaming commission yeah and in Vegas
remember to win jackpots and win all
he's dancing I could tell on him now
he'd win he's beyond the law we're in
California State Lottery he had friends
in there from the Electrolux thank you
hey I could use a couple mil um yeah and
then he divided the money up they'd
break up they'd rigged the [__] and then
they'd divide the money I need to make
friends with some people like that yeah
they were gangsters well maybe not
gangsters
uncle Ronnie was against her concrete
shoes or nothing like that but you need
a couple million and then just retired
out of California
big old house on top of hill and
everything with a circular driveway it
went up I think it's over well in Palos
Verdes I don't think it might have been
palsbury is [__] Swanky he's like
yeah
use gangster yeah
all right so um yeah so Dreamscape uh
from 1984. I feel like if you haven't
seen it in a long time like check it out
again because you know the special
effects do it kind of dated and
everything like that but I mean you have
to think that this is the same year
you know as far as special effects were
concerned this is the same year that
Ghostbusters came out and the effects in
Ghostbusters still look good yeah and I
mean but that movie was like to be fair
like much more expensive than this one
was yeah it was more ambitious too this
is something that they knocked out just
in a year or so yeah yeah yeah so but I
really do like the story behind this and
I had forgotten how it kind of has
something for everybody like I said it's
kind of like a 70s conspiracy Thriller
it's kind of got like sci-fi it's got
some horror [__] in it it's not as scary
as I remember it being like some of the
nightmare sequences are really good and
are like really creepy and stuff but
it's mostly like a conspiracy Thriller
and it also kind of has like a weird
romance kind of angle to it I don't know
I put it up there with fire starter it
reminds me of Fire Starter better
quality than Firestarter yeah if fire
starter and
um
uh altercation Altered States had a baby
you know exactly I was thinking that
it'd be like it would be visually do you
know what you're thinking yeah yeah
about like all Dalton state it did
remind me a lot of Altered States yeah
and like I said Altered States you know
Tammy said that it came out in 1980s
that was four years before this just
because in the sense that Altered States
also had that role weird I did like the
way they shot the dream sequences in
this like they looked kind of realistic
but they shot him with like weird lenses
and stuff so they looked like slightly
hyper real you know what I mean like
kind of weird not fisheye lenses but
like really super wide ones so it would
be like kind of weird and distorted
around the edges and it looked kind of
weird and flat yeah so oh and I forgot
he did that nightmare sequence with that
dude like the construction worker like
Up on the Roof too yeah like they just
started making a lot they just started
making movies of this genre yeah you
know back in the 70s
yeah and this is just one one of them it
was it's one of the good better ones
though and I feel like a lot of people
have kind of forgotten about it yeah I
mean I sort of forgot about it even
though I saw it a bunch of times on
cable back then but later on it evolved
in a [__] like flatliners movies like
that yeah remember that people doing
death experiments and stuff yeah I still
like flatliners yeah
there's there was there was a couple of
them that were like that I've forgotten
the other yes you'd have to be reminded
of their uh
the names of them but
flatliners I remember was a lot more
artistic when they didn't have a lot of
really good visuals really good color
palette yeah it was real stylish yeah
because we reviewed it a couple years
back and I had forgotten I saw that in
the theater I remember yeah
this one I can't remember I might have
seen this in the theater
but I'm pretty sure
I don't know because I remember very
specifically seeing Ghostbusters in the
theater and that was the same year that
this came out
so I feel like I would have remembered
if I had saw this in the theater I think
I saw it on VHS or
on cable like so it was probably like a
year later I'd imagine or however long
it was but I remember really liking it
like I said it's not a horror movie
really but it does have like some horror
elements in it that are really well done
we were talking about this movie and
then Ghostbusters for some reason I
thought of that old [__] movie Dr
Detroit remember how [__] oh [__]
yeah [__] was terrible I I like
those Brothers kinda yeah I remember I
don't remember much about it I remember
it I remember even not really liking it
that much at the time no but I haven't
seen it in a really long time so it was
like a comedy yeah it was like everybody
about hookers it was like too zany for
me I feel like I think that was what
because I like comedy but if it goes
like to zany like where it seems like to
try hard then I'm just like yeah it's
not funny then I like I like more subtle
humor or if you're gonna go zany like at
least go like I don't know like dark
comedy or something I don't I don't like
when they try too hard to be funny you
know what I mean but yeah so uh I think
we watched this on 2B I don't even
remember like what uh streaming platform
it's on anymore but I just like saw it
when I was scrolling through and I'm
like holy [__] I wanted to see that
again because I remembered the snake
monster and that was about it so you
know if you haven't seen in a while it
actually still holds up pretty good I
think and it was an inspiration for a
lot of movies that came later like I
said like the cell and Inception and
stuff like that which had real similar
themes so you know
so yeah uh it's Sunday so tomorrow is
Monday obviously that's how that usually
happens yeah and that means that it's
time for haunting Monday tomorrow and
the one we're doing tomorrow is from
season seven uh episode three because
we've already done a couple of season
seven ones a while back and this one is
called demon Unearthed yeah we've just
watched it we watched it like earlier
like this morning yeah this is a pretty
good one yeah yeah so we're gonna be
talking about that one uh tomorrow so
hopefully you guys can join us tomorrow
evening at 7 30 p.m Eastern Standard
Time and we'll talk about some ghosts
and [__] like that so until then have a
good rest of your Sunday you guys have a
good day tomorrow and we'll see you guys
again tomorrow evening good night